hi I'm gotta yo I'm Garrett we love to
travel but the term room service makes
us think two things expensive and
mediocre
we're looking for the best room service
in the world to see if we can't find
some luxury in this so-called luxury
experience yet because eating cold
chicken tenders at the foot of the bed
really doesn't count today we're
checking in and checking out petit
Armitage in West Hollywood California
[Music]
during our stay we're gonna have room
service three times breakfast dinner and
late night we'll evaluate each meal on
taste and luxury we're going to tell you
which one's our favorite that way you'll
know if you're gonna splurge on room
service just once which meal should it
be you're welcome
nice petit Armitage is a boutique hotel
in West Hollywood California it's got a
little bit of a romantic flair with a
touch of fantasy it's really an escape
from what you imagined to be like a
typical Hollywood hotel we offer a
unique array of room service experiences
that is gonna be hard to find somewhere
else I've got this bed this place is
awesome it is look at this like sitting
area we have a living room it feels like
my grandma's house it's got a fireplace
oh this is very comfortable yo you're
missing now go ahead jump I'm tired
when I order breakfast to be delivered
tomorrow you breakfast in bed
yep order up all right we'd like some
breakfast so for breakfast we offer the
accent Orchestra wake-up call we're
challenging the traditional wake-up call
by doing something that will just make
your day feel like no other name
[Music]
you'll wake up to the sounds of the
orchestra playing beautiful music the
light pouring in through the windows the
chickens accompanied by two clowns
serving breakfast in bed on a silver
platter what just happen this is a fancy
hotel I'm ready to eat this what do you
have I've got a salmon omelette with a
salad and avocado toast and the spiciest
orange juice I've ever had I got a
french toast and I have an Omni
[Applause]
I was there Alma who's a magazine was a
guy like cheese and stuff in it jeez I
think I had pastrami I don't know what
this is that it is pastrami that's
prosciutto I knew that I was want to see
who you're paying says so how do you
feel don't you feel like a king eating
this in the morning that's one of the
most luxurious things that's ever
happened to me people just waking me up
with live music it feels magical
yeah you think this is how Mickey Mouse
wakes up every day exactly
we woke up like Mickey Mouse that French
chose him to sing what's inside of it
french toast more french toast prince to
decide to french toast no matter what
i've already had an incredible day
nobody's gonna mess it up like what else
could happen today and yeah if they
started the day like this early today
wake up clowns never sleep what that's
what I heard
I'm Wikipedia research hi so what you
wanna do for day Wow
run around explore i'ma go upstairs
check out the pool and that's about it
we can't do that all day when it comes
to time away from work it's time to
relax I'm gonna get ready for the day
I'm gonna take it in the bathroom with
me don't we eat mmm oh all right well
God yell hangs out by the pool all day
I'm going to go out and explore City oh
my god people this is amazing look at
this pool feel like I'm the king of Los
Angeles I am here look
the Pacific Ocean the stores there's
food oh my god the dolphin oh that's so
cool please like this is nice to relax
enjoy yourself but just enjoy the moment
hey man hey man whoa there's a dog it's
a dog a little chihuahua oh hey buddy
who brought you here yeah what is this
dear Gary and Gary oh we hope your stay
with us is weird and wonderful please
enjoy this bottle of crazy juice on us
[Music]
what is this chocolate cassava
ooh are we supposed to snort that
[Music]
you hungry I'm always hungry hi I'd like
to order some dinner
[Music]
oh you're looking good man so do you man
right for dinner yes for dinner service
we offer the unique experience of being
served by two clowns oh man hey which
obviously makes for an unforgettable
dining experience oh my goodness
[Music]
do you need help that was the trip all
right you want some of the salad no I'm
not a static guy I'm more of a
meat-eater
you gonna dive straight into that yes
try the chimichurri yeah boom double
dipping that's a win right there hmm
that's so good Oh like a gravy kind of
all shoe kind of thing
how'd you I never heard that woman I
like just like me truce Nietzsche to the
summary that's why it's called Oz you
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm you can taste the char that it was
like cooking at shall we
Wow this is the best offer I've ever
tasted
I've had lobster before but nothing
where like you're tasting in sort of
preparation method is so tender and
juicy there's like five different
flavors you're tasting at the same time
grapefruit kale and like guacamole how's
that work it's so good
[Music]
fun fact I'm allergic to shrimp you're
allergic to shrimp
yeah bye I still eat it almost as good
as hell I eat it too like Mike I feel
like a like a itchiness in my throat and
that's my like okay that's my body
telling me this stuff you probably don't
you stop it was before that I haven't
died yet at least slow down stop it
tastes so good I have to hear all so you
don't die I'm a die happy I never
thought about dinner in a hotel if
hotels going through the effort to do
this this is an event of itself special
people coming in and delivering special
food to you it makes a whole special
experience
and I'm glad I'm spending this time with
you Kara thanks God yo Spence with you
too
what's the plan for the rest tonight
maybe get a drink of the rooftop yeah
busy bulls and all that I'm down we
would bring the dog with us where is
that dog oh the dog
[Music]
yo you guys do late night night a word
yeah let me get two for me and my buddy
and for late night we have the Toledo
turndown service would be better if you
just sit down the same bed next to him
[Music]
imagine a woody priest tucking you in
and feeding you cookies and milk as he's
reading your a bedtime story
so gentlemen these are the tales of
twisted fairy tales from the book that I
read all the mazes used to say they
didn't want to go into the forest for
fear for lurked inside at all sure
everybody wants to run their fingers
through the wild first I just want to
wrap around them back tonight and rise
she said make me howl like a mad dog at
the moon until he milk and cookies
gentlemen he didn't even read night
Garrett good I got y'all
good morning good morning
any good trip it was amazing let's do it
again tomorrow all right god yeah what
was the best food what was the most
luxurious experience if you only do one
which would you do french toast was
amazing
yes but that ribeye and lobster together
as a room service what about you
that dry-aged rib eye was so good and
that like char on the lobster most
luxurious experience I always say waking
up in the morning with music GEMA feet
but I roll the tea at that point except
the chickens they got it go son for me
something about just somebody coming in
telling you a story that's just for you
there's no room service like that if
you'd only do one what would you do I
would say the breakfast in bed it was
magical and I stopped for that happy
music in the morning I think I agree
having just this silver tray on your lap
you have to feel special we gotta check
out hey goodbye petite Marmot eyes
thanks for the great stay
[Music]